hey guys today it is the 14th of July my
name is Jess McDowell and you're
watching games what news a blog post
landed from star wars battlefront
developer dice which are answers some of
our burning questions about the upcoming
shooter community manager Matthew
Everett has confirmed that split screen
play which will only be supported in
missions mode will be available on Xbox
one and ps4 so no split screen on the pc
version missions is the mode where you
fight off waves of AI enemies solo or
co-op basically it's a horde mode
Everett also discussed how vehicles will
work in the game explaining in Walker
assault vehicles are tied to the powerup
system when you find a vehicle power up
on the map you will need to activate it
which immediately spawns you inside the
vehicle vehicle power up specifically
must be used within a certain amount of
time he added that y-wing bombers are
support vehicles only and a not player
controlled and that while missions won't
grant you multiplayer career experience
they will give you credit rewards that
you can spend on unlocks things appear
to be going from worse to insulting for
the relationship between Konami and
kajima productions as Konami have
removed all mention of Hideo Kojima and
his studio from middle gear solid 5 the
phantom pain box art in March of this
year Konami removed kajima branding from
the artwork and marketing material for
both metal gear solid 5 ground 0 and the
phantom pain but up until now the
Phantom Pain's actual box art had
remained untouched where previous assets
featured the kojima productions logo and
the line 80 day Okajima game the final
versions of the box art Carrie no
mention of kajima this news has come
just days after otsuka Akio snakes
Japanese voice actor said that the
studio was disbanded Konami had also
previously removed Kojima Productions
branding off the silent Hills website
before that project with cancelled for a
timeline of all the Konami Kojima drama
collated in one place head to our story
on gamespot the prototype abaayo has a
was announced today which includes HD
remasters of both installments of the
dark open-world action game for Xbox one
and ps4 Activision have released an
action-packed mutated protagonist heavy
trailer to get you in the mood for the
upcoming remaster bundle the publisher
have promised full HD visuals and
improved frame rate and increased
texture resolution the bundle is
actually out right now but after you've
also announced that you can pick up each
game individually in their new and
improved current-gen form on august 11
let me know down in the comments if
you're keen to play prototype again or
if you think HD remasters are just a
cash grab you can head to gamespot for
stories on how the ps4 benefits
uncharted and naughty don't blow
expectations for the last of us that is
everything I wanted to tell you about
today let me know down in the comments
what matter to you and I will catch you
tomorrow